the southern German state of Bavaria has
canceled the Oktoberfest beer festival
because of the coronavirus the event
attracts more than 6 million visitors
every year and authorities feared
allowing it to go ahead would lead to a
spike in infections as we report the
move is likely to take both a financial
and an emotional toll no crowded party
tents giant mugs of beer or packed out
parades Germany's biggest festival has
been canceled for the first time since
World War two large events are currently
banned in Germany until the end of
August Oktoberfest was supposed to start
on September 19th but officials say the
risk of infection during the corona
virus pandemic is just too high it is
painful for us it is a great pity but as
with many things this is not a normal
year and this is sadly going to be a
year without the festival about 6
million visitors flocked to the
Oktoberfest every year crowding the
festival grounds but also the host city
Munich the cancellation of the event is
not only sad news for the city it also
means big financial losses surveys show
between 1.2 and 1.3 billion euros of
lost profits in these 16 days this
affects hotels restaurants outside the
Oktoberfest but also the cab drivers
everyone will miss the Oktoberfest
terribly their wallets will too
and so begins the countdown until 2021
when the next Oktoberfest will hopefully
take place let's speak to correspondent
Bastian Herto he's standing by for us in
Munich hi Bastian the mayor of Munich
has said this is an emotionally
difficult moment to cancel the
Oktoberfest why is it so emotional
well absolutely it is because you have
to understand that for the city of
Munich and for the people who live here
the Oktoberfest is much more than just
another huge party it's got a really
long tradition it's been around for more
than 200 years and it's something that's
deeply ingrained into the DNA of this
city and on top of that it's also shaped
the image of not only Munich and Bavaria
but also to a certain degree all of
Germany really all around the world if
you ask anyone anywhere of what they
associate with Germany one of the first
answers that you always get is going to
be the Oktoberfest so it's usually
popular around the world in the city and
the people here in the city of Munich
they're proud of that they're proud of
the fact that their city is home to such
a famous and popular festival and of
course now they're sad that this year
all those visitors from around the world
can't can't come here and can't take
place if they can't take part in the
Oktoberfest and that just huge festival
it's not going to be happening what
about the economic impact of all of this
I mean this is a multi-million euro
business isn't it absolutely as we heard
in the report it's won between 1.2 and
1.3 billion euros that the Oktoberfest
generates every year and that's not only
for the businesses that are directly at
the Oktoberfest so the beer halls
breweries and the rides and everything
that that you always see when you see
the Oktoberfest it's the whole
hospitality sector as we heard in the
report around 1 million people spend the
night in Munich I'm during the
Oktoberfest and that's for a city that
only has around one and a half million
people a population so you can you can
already tell that that's a huge factor
for a lot of businesses here in the
hospitality sector and that of course is
a sector that's already heavily affected
by the coronavirus this year so the
cancellation of the Oktoberfest for them
is just really another blow to the guts
to me all right so it's a big blow but
by saying given the current situation
with the pandemic in Germany also
internationally
does it really come as a surprise that
Oktoberfest has been canceled no I don't
think so I mean a lot of people expected
this there's really no way to go forward
with this we heard in the report like
all the big events in Germany are
canceled until the end of August says
other big events around the world like
the Olympics that are also canceled so
that you really can't go ahead with an
event like this where there's millions
of people from around the world coming
together partying together being close
to each other you can't really social
distance yourself at all during your
tour fest of course and that's not the
point of the festival so then people get
infected they go home to their home
countries and then maybe spark more
outbreaks and the last thing that the
authorities hear and that the city of
Munich wants to be associated with is
another wave in this pandemic or be the
the cause for another wave in this
pandemic so they're the only responsible
decision to really make here is to
cancel the Oktoberfest as hard as it is
but a lot of people on Twitter for
example they're always saying okay we're
looking forward to the next Oktoberfest
in 2021
all right correspondent bossy and heart
aches speaking to us from Munich good to
talk to you let's take a look now at
other coronavirus news as several
countries are starting to ease their
lockdowns including Germany now Italy
says that before the end of this week it
will outline plans for the gradual
easing of lockdown restrictions starting
on the 4th of May several US states have
announced reopening schedules Georgia is
aiming to restart its economy by the
weekend
but the World Health Organization has
warned that rushing to ease restrictions
will increase the risk of a resurgence
of the disease the global death toll
stands at nearly 170 1,400 according to
Johns Hopkins University in the US